esto que tenemos aquí es la gráfica de
igual al valor absoluto de x con la cual
quizá ustedes estén familiarizados si x
es igual a menos 2 el valor absoluto de
2 es igual a 2 para x igual a menos 1 el
valor absoluto de esto va a ser igual a
1 para 0 el valor absoluto de 0 es cero
para uno su valor absoluto es 1 y así
sucesivamente lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es ver cómo va a cambiar esta
ecuación si desplazáramos esta gráfica
en particular vamos a pensar cómo será
la ecuación de esta gráfica así la
desplazamos tres unidades a la derecha y
luego veremos cómo cambia esto si no
sólo desplazamos esta gráfica 3 a la
derecha sino que también la desplazamos
4 arriba
y nuevamente los invito a como siempre a
que pause en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta como será la
ecuación si desplazamos esta gráfica
tres unidades a la derecha y después se
desplazan cuatro hacia arriba primero
vamos a desplazar la 3 a la derecha y
pensemos cómo cambia esto a la ecuación
para visualizar lo que vamos a hacer
vamos a copiar esta gráfica y vamos a
desplazar las tres unidades a la derecha
y ahora queremos encontrar la ecuación
de esta gráfica como lo hacemos una
forma de pensar en esto es darnos cuenta
de que está ocurriendo algo interesante
aquí cuando x es igual a 3 antes esta
cosa interesante ocurría cuando x era
igual a 0 pero ahora ocurre cuando x es
igual a 3 aquí lo interesante es que
intercambiamos signos adentro del valor
absoluto así que aquí en lugar de tener
el valor absoluto de un negativo ahora
tomamos el valor absoluto conforme
atravesamos este punto de un positivo y
es por eso que aquí vemos un cambio de
dirección en esta línea y ahora podemos
ver que esto mismo ocurre ahora aquí así
que sabemos que en este punto de aquí
nuestra ecuación se va a evaluar en 0 es
en este punto en donde se va a
intercambiar el signo así que decimos
bueno esto luce como un valor absoluto
así que la ecuación tendrá la forma de
que es igual al valor absoluto de algo
ahora si x es igual a 3 como puedo hacer
esto igual a cero bueno le puedo restar
3 a x si digo que es igual al valor
absoluto de x menos 3 tiene sentido
vamos a verlo cuando x es igual a 33
menos tres es cero el valor absoluto de
esto es cero esto funciona cuando x es
igual a 44 menos 3 es igual a 1 y el
valor absoluto de 1 es 1 y si
x es igual a 22 menos 3 es igual a menos
1 y el valor absoluto de menos 1 es 1 y
aquí estamos probando algunos números
para que ustedes tengan una intuición de
qué es lo que está pasando aquí ya que
esto no es obvio la primera vez que lo
vemos el hecho de que desplazamos esto
hacia la derecha que pareciera que
estamos aumentando el valor en x en
realidad lo que estamos haciendo es
reemplazar mi x con una x menos la
cantidad que estoy desplazando hacia la
derecha los invito a que traten de
probar esto con distintos números y
traten de ver qué es lo que ocurre aquí
en este vértice de aquí lo que sea que
tengamos como valor absoluto lo estamos
igualando a cero
en este punto cualquier cosa que
tengamos adentro de estos signos de
valor absoluto va a pasar de signos
negativos a signos positivos así que
nuevamente si desplazamos esto tres
unidades a la derecha este vértice tiene
que ocurrir cuando x es igual a 3
así que lo que sea que tengamos adentro
de los signos de valor absoluto va a
tener que ser igual a 0 en este vértice
vamos en el vídeo y reflexionen sobre
esto si es que esto tiene sentido y
conforme se familiaricen más con esto
los invito a que lo prueben con diversos
números no es solo memorizar el que sí
desplazó a la derecha tengo que restarle
a x la cantidad que lo desplace hacia la
derecha siempre hagan la prueba con
diferentes números para que se den una
idea de él porque esto funciona ahora
partamos de este punto y ahora vamos a
desplazar hacia arriba 4 unidades
desplazar 4 hacia arriba es de cierta
manera un poco más intuitivo vamos a
hacerlo
vamos a desplazar esto cuatro arriba
movemos 1 2
y 4 estos se desplazan cuatro arriba
recordemos lo que hicimos en la primera
parte desplazamos esta gráfica 3 a la
derecha y ahora esto se desplaza 4
arriba antes esto era igual a 0 antes y
era igual a 0 aquí pero ahora ya tiene
que ser igual a 4 así que cualquiera que
sea lo que evalúa vamos aquí ahora le
tenemos que incrementar cuatro cuando
desplazamos esto 3 a la derecha nuestra
ecuación resultó ser igual al valor
absoluto de x menos 3 pero ahora a
cualquier valor que teníamos antes le
tenemos que aumentar 4 unidades ya que
aumentamos en la dirección vertical por
lo que solamente agregamos 4 esto tiene
un poco más de sentido si nuestro
desplazamiento es en la dirección
vertical si el desplazamiento es hacia
arriba
en esta dirección vertical simplemente
vamos a agregar la cantidad de unidades
que desplazamos
y lo desplazamos hacia abajo cuatro
unidades aquí tendríamos que restar un 4
aquí en lo menos intuitivo es lo que
hicimos con x cuando desplazamos a la
derecha tenemos que reemplazar nuestra x
con x menos la cantidad que desplazamos
a la derecha pero nuevamente prueba en
esto con diversos números para que
puedan encontrar el sentido a esto así
que obtuvimos aquí la ecuación de esta
gráfica de acá y es igual al valor
absoluto de x menos 34